three
next on american history tv a discussion
on the assassination of senator robert f
kennedy
it was 44 years ago just after midnight
on june 5th 1968
when kennedy was shot at the ambassador
hotel in los angeles while campaigning
for the democratic presidential
nomination
panelists include evan thomas author of
the book robert kennedy his life and the
police officer who arrested sirhan
sirhan later convicted as the assassin
the panel was hosted by the national law
enforcement museum it's about an hour
and ten minutes
all right i want to welcome everyone
so glad you've joined us here this
evening we're going to have a fabulous
discussion we've got some wonderful
guests that i'll introduce in a moment
this is a special program we call
witness to history
i'm craig floyd i'm the chairman and ceo
of the national law enforcement officers
memorial fund and it's my pleasure to
moderate this evening's event
for those of you who may not be familiar
with the memorial fund and i don't think
there's too many of you but we do have a
television audience that's joining us
here this evening our organization was
formed in 1984.
our primary mission at that time was to
build the first ever national law
enforcement officers memorial
that memorial as i think most of us know
was dedicated in 1991
it sits just a few blocks from where we
are here tonight place called judiciary
square and on the walls of that memorial
are the names of 19
660 law enforcement professionals who
have been killed in the line of duty
dating back to that first death in 1791.
we're now in the process of building the
first ever national law enforcement
museum
that's a museum that was authorized by
the united states congress in 2000
and that museum groundbreaking was held
in october of 2010
the scheduled opening is late 2014
so we are on the verge uh seeing
daylight there at the end of the tunnel
of opening uh this wonderful museum that
will for the first time ever tell the
story of american law enforcement
we feel though that
we are already in many ways a museum we
have a collection that has more than 15
000 artifacts and documents
films as well as oral histories
and we also have been putting on a
number of public programs and
educational programs in the schools
and in the community
tonight is a good example of that we
call this program witness to history
it is a program that started last year
this is our fourth in a series of
witness to history events
the first was
last year with a gentleman named jim
lavelle he was a retired dallas police
detective who was escorting lee harvey
oswald in that iconic photo when he was
shot and killed by jack ruby he was 92
years old jim lavelle last year when he
was with us and he told the story
his experience we then had a 10th
anniversary reflection on 9 11.
we had three
participants who were key figures in the
9 11 rescue and recovery effort
and then our most recent witness to
history event was the 30th anniversary
earlier this year of the air florida
crash here in washington that occurred
in 1982.
the idea is to focus on significant
events in law enforcement history which
often times means our nation's history
and talk about those events and get
perspectives from the people that know
those events the best especially those
who have been witnesses to those events
and in many cases participants tonight
we focus on the 44th anniversary of the
assassination of robert f kennedy by
sirhan sirhan
mr kennedy was the younger brother of
president john f kennedy
he was a former attorney general of the
united states a sitting united states
senator at the time of his death
and a candidate for president of the
united states when he was shot on june
5th
1968 44 years ago today
and as has been the case with our
earlier programs
this event tonight will be filmed by
c-span made available to the public
and will also be filmed by our film crew
at the national law enforcement museum
and it will become a permanent part of
our museum archives
let me introduce now very briefly the
speakers for tonight's event our
witnesses to history
first we have to my right evan thomas a
well-known writer and editor at time and
newsweek
as a frequent guest on television news
shows
nationally and certainly here in the
washington dc area he's also the
best-selling author of eight books
including a biography on robert f
kennedy it's entitled robert kennedy
his life and a copy of it i hold in my
hand and i evan i certainly hope before
you leave here tonight we'll get you to
autograph this for the national law
enforcement museum collection
we also have retired los angeles police
officer art placencia
art
was the arresting officer of sirhan
sirhan and he was only three weeks out
of the police academy when he made the
arrest so it was the beginning of a long
and nearly 40-year career with the los
angeles police department and we're
honored and very privileged to have art
with us here tonight
and to add some perspective kind of
frame the issue of uh protection of uh
presidential candidates the security
that was in place then and the security
that's in place now much different as
we'll soon learn and that's going to be
given to us by secret service special
agent stephen hughes he's the special
agent in charge of the dignitary
protection division of the united states
secret service and he's based here in
washington dc so steve thank you for
joining us uh representing the u.s
secret service
let's start now with uh evan the first
question goes to you and i'd like you to
help frame the event and the issue
before us tonight the assassination of
robert f kennedy
who was this man and uh and and then
let's talk about his assassin and how
they came together on june 5th 1968.
uh robert kennedy was
an unusual candidate for president but
1968 was a very
unusual year there was a sitting
president lyndon johnson he had won by a
landslide in 1964
but as uh some of you old enough to
remember in 1968 was a very volatile
time the vietnam war was becoming
increasingly unpopular
there were tremendous racial tensions
particularly in the cities uh there was
it was a very strange and scary time to
a lot of americans
and uh
lbj's presidency was under threat within
his own party
the first person to take a run at him
was gene mccarthy
who
definitely had the college students with
him
the anti-vietnam vote
johnson at first didn't take mccarthy
very seriously and then mccarthy almost
beat him in the new hampshire primary
it was a wake-up call
bobby kennedy was reluctant to get in
the race uh there was a lot of pressure
on him to get in he was after all the
brother of
john f kennedy uh he was a u.s senator
from new york he was an increasingly
effective voice against the vietnam war
but
he had real reservations he didn't want
to split the party
uh he had bad blood with uh johnson that
he didn't want to make
any worse
and something deeper he wasn't really
sure he was up to it he was uh he'd
always been the brother protector he'd
been the guy who worked behind the
scenes to protect his brother to help to
do the to do and campaigns the dirty
work uh even handing out the money in
the old days
and he was not a big public figure he
was not this glamorous charming man that
his brother had been
but
he was under a lot of pressure to to
carry his brother's torch
and to
to
run against linda johnson
and he finally in march of 1968
decided after having said he wouldn't do
it decided he would do it
he got a late start but his campaign was
an instant
kind of spectacle and sensation it was a
very
hot campaign
huge crowds
people yearning for the memory of his
dead brother
uh people who were fascinated by this by
this man who was in many ways shy
his hands shook when he had to grip the
podium to keep his hands from shaking
when he gave a speech
he was uncomfortable around people and
yet he conveyed a sense of
fierceness
and a sense of vulnerability that was
very effective he was that unusual thing
he was a white candidate who black
voters really loved
he attracted big black crowds
and he could get he could do something
very unusual he'd get the votes
of steel workers and and
blue collar whites and blacks that was
unusual in 1968 to be able to put that
together and so his campaign sort of
rolled along
picking up steam in a way that was scary
to some people now the security on it is
by modern standards laughable
he had a bodyguard a former fbi agent
named bill barry he used to hold and
they were in open cars
convertibles and barry would kneel and
hold robert kennedy by the waist as he's
nailed in fact ethel had to give a put a
pillow under uh barry's knees because he
ended up hurting his knees uh
crowds would just come in and sometimes
pull kennedy right out of the car i
think we've got a photograph of it here
somewhere he during the course of the
campaign they would rip off his
cufflinks they would tear his shirt they
pulled him out of the car he chipped a
tooth on a curb can you imagine
they one lady reached in and took his
shoe
it was just wild i have a i have some
photos in my book and i think i've seen
him up there it was just a kind of a
free-for-all
uh when bill barry hurt his back they
got a little more security they got a
former football player named roosevelt
grier a great lineman for the new york
giants and
rayford johnson who had been a great
olympic athlete so they had a little
more security but
when they went to los angeles for
instance
kennedy had a bad relationship with
mayor jordy who had been a foe of his
when kennedy was attorney general and
jordy did not provide police protection
when they went into watts kennedy was
protected by a group called the sons of
watts a local black power movement no
cops in fact the lapd gave kennedy's
motorcade a traffic ticket
so it was just a kind of a it was kind
of a free-for-all well kennedy
won some early primaries he lost in
oregon and then
california was the big one he really had
to win that
in june of 1968
he did win
fairly narrowly but he won
he's at the ambassador hotel
in los angeles uh it's about uh
uh
nine uh i guess it was almost midnight
uh
when he gives his victory speech and he
says something about uh you know we won
tonight on to chicago which is where the
convention was going to be let's win
there
now as he leaves the podium his
bill barry uh tries to aim him out the
front door his one bodyguard but there
are some screaming girls
teeny bobbers bobby was sort of a
sex object
and uh girls would surround them
squealing girls and they somehow
separated bobby from his bodyguard
the hotel maitre d
turned bobby around and directed him not
at the front door but through the back
into
the pantry of the kitchen
now waiting there sitting on a on a
serving tray basically was a man named
saran saron who was a mentally impaired
he was a palestinian and as far as we
know
he had once seen bobby kennedy on a tv
broadcast outside a synagogue
in los angeles wearing a yarmulke and
this somehow triggered something in uh
cyron saron and made him want to kill
him and he got a cheap handgun and he
just was able to sachet right into the
kitchen and just by luck because bobby
was supposed to go out the other way
just by luck he's turned around and
comes in through the kitchen siron saron
fires wildly and got lucky one bullet i
think was a 22 lodged itself and the
soft tissue right about here went into
his brain probably instantly brain dead
it took him another 25 hours to die but
he was as good as dead right away there
was this wild melee to disarm sir on
saron there's some photographs of that
up there and uh
with that i guess i'll turn it over to
art thank you art you've now gotten the
call all right you're a 21 year old los
angeles police officer three weeks out
of the academy uh what call did you get
what did you know when you arrived at
the ambassador hotel
well let me let me start off with
my exact age i just turned 21 on
november the 20th
1967
and this happened six months later so i
talk about being just i retire i
graduated from the academy on may 17
1968
and this happened three weeks later
and uh
basically what was going on is i was
assigned to rampart division and i was
assigned to a watch called the midwatch
and we started at six o'clock in the
evening and we went until 2 30 in the
morning anyway that
about 12 15
on the 5th of june
we were about we were at vermont and 7th
street which is in the wilshire district
area
and a call came out on the radio all
units in the vicinity
ambulance shooting 3400 wilshire 3400
wilshire is the address of the
ambassador hotel
and we were approximately four to five
we were five blocks away from the
ambassador
so at that time i was working with my
training officer and my training
officer's name was travis white and i
believe travis only had like two years
on the job
so we immediately turned on the red
lights and sirens and we
we traveled west on wilshire boulevard
and we got to the entrance of the
ambassador hotel and at the entrance of
the ambassador hotel it's a it's it's a
long entrance it's a one way going in
and one way coming out so you drive in
and then you have to make a left
into the main entrance where there's a
big canopy
and
we knew exactly where to go because
at that time that used to be one of our
eating spots we we used to eat at the
little restaurant right there and they
used to
you know take care of us you might say
so we we we go on there and we eat so we
we park right in front and as soon as we
got there there was kind of a crowd out
there and then
my partner and i got out of the police
car
and we heard this person yelling this
way officer this way over here and we
look over to our left
and here's this person he was wearing a
tuxedo so he figured well he probably
works here turned out later to be one of
the maitre d's
so as we're looking he's waving he said
this way officer this way he's over here
he's over here
well at that time all we knew was an
ambulance shooting so
we have to assume that it was a call
where somebody was shot somebody was
injured
so we started following him and what we
did is we we didn't going through the
main entrance we went through a side
entrance and it was sort of a ramp that
went
diagonal that went up and then it turned
to the quick to the right and then you
went into an entrance so all this time
this person is saying this way officer
this way he's over here he's over here
so we followed him and what happened is
we go into
this doorway and as soon as we walk into
the doorway
we're in the pantry area which is you
know and there's and there's
uh there's pantry tables to my right and
there's was i think there was three of
them
and
i found out there was three of them
later but i only was able to see the one
but as soon as you walked in i mean
there was
people all over the place they were
yelling and screaming
people were crying and
that person he's saying he's over here
officer he's right there he's right here
he's over here officer and he's pointing
and what he's doing and he's pointing to
this pantry table so we walk in look
directly to the right and there's this
group of people on top
of a pantry table and then we we look
and there's one person has this one
person
and a headlock
and then
there's one person turned out to be
rosie grier
was on top of this person laying on him
with his body and then there was
somebody who was holding his legs
so then there was a group of other
people that were in front they were
trying to hit him you know they were
hitting him and
and then so
the person that was telling us he's over
here officer he's over here he said
that's him that's him he did it
so okay
we got it so
we had to get in there and get this
person out of here still don't know who
he is
so next thing i know we're pulling
people off well here i was rosie grier
you know his big guy little guy you know
back then i was
175 pounds of steel you know
but uh hey you know los angeles police
academy one thing i can say about that
when you come out of there you come out
of there in the best of shape you will
ever be in your life and i felt it then
so anyway the bottom line was rosie
grier was very emotional i knew he was
crying he was like on top of him and you
could tell that he was crying he was
holding on to him so
naturally i asked him very nicely would
you please you know enough but uh we
asked him get off get off get off of him
and then we were able to get sir han
which later we found out it was saran
took him off the table
and we wheeled him around and he was
facing him
and i took my handcuffs off out of my
utility belt and i handcuffed them i was
the officer actually handcuffed them and
i handcuffed them with my uh handcuffs
that were issued to me
five months ago at the academy and uh
can i please just so you know these are
the these are the original handcuffs
that i had
that day they're smith and wesson
handcuffs they're serialized and
the little cat piece
up there is uh it's a policeman cat
piece and that handsome gentleman there
that's me
and the
uh back then we used to be called
policemen because it was policemen
police women but when they started
hiring more females we changed it to
police officers so back then i was a
policeman
and
that those are the original handcuffs
well i had
i'd put them away because i figured when
i retire i'd put them in my shadow box
but
um you know now i'm
going to donate them to the museum
but um so anyway
oh no you know
[Applause]
it was my honor it is really an honor
to know that my handcuffs
and what i did is being focused at this
event here and thank you very much
and welcome mark so anyway uh so we have
so i handcuffed them so here we have
siran
and people are you know coming over us
and trying to hit him and he's a killer
and we're hearing all these kind of
things but in the background i did
remember one thing
this person would kept on saying we
don't want another dallas we don't want
another dallas and i keep hearing we
don't want another dallas
so but that was just one of the things i
was hearing so anyway my partner says
well we got to get him out of here
so
you gotta make here's the pantry and if
you look at these diagrams here the
pantry wasn't that big of an area it
might be might be the size of this area
right in here well we didn't know it at
the time but robert kennedy was still
lying
in the floor over here with the other
people that were shot
but there was so many people there you
couldn't see
you know three or four bodies ahead of
you because everybody was all over the
place it was yelling and screaming
so our main responsibility was this
person
and uh our tell them what you told me
about the gun too oh yeah so anyway
we're well we're still
we have uh sir han it's handcuff and
we're trying to figure out here and then
i stay my partner says where's the gun
who has the gun and then and then uh
somebody said uh rafer johnson has it
and then where's he and he says well i
got the gun but i'm not going to give it
to you i'm going to take it to the
station to the police station
so you know we got him we got people
trying to get to him and he doesn't want
to give up the gun so i said
okay keep it you know
keep the gun you can have it we got the
guy you know
so anyway we ended up with with sirhan
so my partner
uh says well let's get him out of here
so
uh this one another person major deal
with the suit says well you can go out
this way and he points this way so we
look and there's his big double door
well like so here we go my partner says
you lead the way so coming right out of
the academy i was very versed in baton
tactics and you know using my baton so i
started pushing the crowd with my baton
and back then the baton was just a
straight stick with a rubber grommet on
it and it was kind of interesting but so
anyway i laid the way
and here i open up this door and we walk
right into the colonial room where he
had just given a speech
i mean it's like walking in and here's
this room with all these people you know
they're crying or emotional and here we
come walking out with a guy that's
handcuffed so what do you think happened
you know oh my god that's him that's him
so there's trying to get at him and so
i'm trying to push people back out
so we go through the crowd it would be
like breaking right through like you
know breaking the water hearing
everybody out so it went right through
and then there's some steps because we
were like in a second floor area of the
ambassador hotel where the colonial room
is and then you have to go down some
winding stairs that takes you into the
hallway the main hallway of the hotel so
as we're going down you might be able to
see those might show some video on it
but as we're going down people are still
trying to grab at this person you know
they're hitting him and stuff like that
my partner has him on the right and some
other officer has him on the left and
i'm in front
so as we go down we're walking through
the main lobby and people it's like
walking through a gauntlet you know
you're walking and people are just you
know so okay you hit me so you know good
like that so we're so i'm going through
a break and we finally
we get out into the entrance where our
cars park our police car is there so i'm
the first one there
but like they teach you in the counter
says you know whatever you do you don't
leave your car unlocked so guess what i
had to unlock the car so they're trying
to get my keys out of my belt i'm
putting the keys into the right into
this into the right front passenger door
i opened it up open up the door i had to
unbutton the button i open the door the
rear right rear who gets her hand we
throw him in there sit him down on the
right rear and then i come around to the
left side guess what the door on the
left side is locked too so now i got to
use the key to get in the driver's door
unlock that door and then i get into the
back i open the door get into the back
seat so i'm sitting in the back seat
with siren he's on the right i'm on the
left he's about as close to me as
he is as uh steve so anyway here we are
so then my partner gets into the car the
driver and all of a sudden
this person gets in he's wearing a suit
he's wearing he just gets into the
police car
and i'm looking at this but you know
i'm not saying anything because i figure
well maybe you know my training officer
but we didn't say anything so anyway
this person gets in and he's wearing a
suit
we lock the doors and these people are
just hitting the car and hitting the
windows because we rolled up the windows
were rolled up and everything so they're
hitting on the windows you know he did
that caliber and all these other kind of
crazy things
so
my partner says okay we got to get out
of here so he turns on the red lights
and then the lights start flashing and
some people kind of back off he kind of
he buzzes the siren and back then we
didn't have these electronics back then
we used to have these round sirens what
used to go around like this well
back then you know when the sirens got
real old we used to have to stick paper
in them so the siren wouldn't blow when
you were driving you know because you
know the wind would cause it to blow and
they would go oh you know
so we had paper but anyway this time we
had these so we we turned a siren on and
it you know so it went on a couple of
times people backed off and then we left
we left the uh
the ambassador hotel so at that time
like i said you know all this was
happening between us sirhan and i didn't
know who it what had happened who had
been shot or anything all we knew is
that
this was the guy that did it
okay so we knew that we had the bad guy
so
are you raising your hand i am i have a
question
well let me tell you it was pretty fast
but um
the uh
if i might just for our audience in
television's sake the question that was
asked is what was the timeline after you
had gotten to the hotel and how long did
it take to get sir and surhan out of the
hotel into the car well you know we were
talking about this we
we've the call actually came out about
12 15 i figured it took about 20 minutes
to get to the ambassador
and up to the pantry area so from the
time that we actually handcuffed them
and got them out of there i would have
said it probably was 15 to 20 minutes
that was that fast
and and it was all through a crowd of
people
so 15 to 20 minutes for the time that i
got him in the car and to think about it
it probably was a total of
45 minutes from the time that we got the
call to the time that we actually got
him out of there so so you can see how
things were really moving fast i mean
everything was just popping
so anyway here i am sitting in the back
seat with sirhan
we're driving off we drive up out of the
entrance of the ambassador and instead
of going back on wilshire we went
straight across and we went to rampart
station so on our way to ramp our
station
my partner says advise him of his rights
so back then we have this little field
officer's notebook with the admonition
the rights i take out my little field
officer's notebook and i look at him and
i start saying you have the right to
remain silent
and i'm giving him his right but he's
just handcuffed and he's basically just
down like this looking like this
so anyway
i'm thinking i said well if you look at
his picture he looks hispanic well back
there everybody looked hispanic to me
and i've never seen a palestinian before
so
anyway he so he left hispanics i said
well maybe he speaks spanish so i
started
you know you know said you know
davos ingles and he's still like this so
what i had my flashlight back then and
what i did is i nudged him i gave him a
couple of nudges in the chin and on the
way back and he's handcuffed like this
and he just basically he just looks at
me like this and goes i'll remember 3909
and then he went back down
and i go
and then now you think about it 3909 was
actually my badge number
so i'm thinking i'll go wow
with everything that's going on
this guy's getting choked i mean and
like i said 15 minutes from the time
that we got him i mean he's seen all
this and this guy
remembers my badge number
and
i mean i probably remembered my best
number only had it for
six months but this guy said i'll
remember 3909. in fact in my retirement
flyer i have a little picture of him
behind bars saying i'll remember 3909.
but uh
and uh so anyway he says that and then
they uh
he uh
and then so there we are in the car so
then i'm looking at this person and i
and i asked this person i go
by the way
who did he shoot
i like i said i still didn't know i said
i still didn't know he goes
i asked this person i go who did he
shoot
and he turned and he goes bobby kennedy
and i go like you know like whoa you
know and then i look at him and i go by
the way who are you
and he goes i'm jesse unra well i knew
who jesse unruh was back then i mean
i'd never really seen him but i knew the
name i go jesse enroll and i go oh
you know i was 21 would i you know what
i carry
21.
so i said oh okay
so then there we go so art if i might
just jump in jesse unruh for those of us
who may not know as i learned later uh
was the speaker of the house of
representatives in california uh one of
their top legislators and he was also
the california campaign chairman for uh
bobby kennedy's presidential bid so
obviously he was very personally
affected by what had happened and i
assume that's probably why he jumped in
the car where he saw the assassin being
placed well yeah
we were talking about that too we're
saying well why did you let him get in
the car
well you know with everything going on
you know what are you going to do you
know we're going to take this guy out or
we're going to just take him with us so
we took him with us
but any other time would have thrown
them out of course you know
but so anyway we get to the station
and uh we have sunrise to get out of the
car
and then we we take uh my partner and i
we
there was a underground garage
and we uh takes her hand out of the car
and we take him upstairs to an interview
room
and we
placed him in the interview room and
excuse me i took the handcuffs off of
him
and my partner said well let's take
everything out of his pockets
so between my partner myself we took
everything out of his pocket
pockets and as i recall he had a hundred
dollar bill he had a set of keys with a
with a chrysler had a chrysler key in it
and that night after we saw him was
taken they asked us to go
try every chrysler car within the area
of the ambassador hotel to see if this
key fit any car and it's really funny
because we found a car that the key fit
but it turned out to be the wrong car
so we said oh we got the car we got the
car but it wasn't the right car so
anyway later on they found the car
because they got ticketed and they found
the car that he apparently had gone
there and there but i also remember that
there was a 22 long bullet
an unexpended 22 long bullet well
for those of you that don't know the gun
that sirhan used was a
ivor johnson eight shot revolver
and it shot 22 longs
so
he had that one bullet i remember that
and he had some change and that was
about it so we took everything out of
there and
we started inventorying it
and about 10-15 minutes later the
detectives showed up
and
they got all the items that we had they
grabbed them up sort of like the secret
service they just grabbed everything up
and left
but anyway they uh they came and it kind
of basically gave a little story what
happened and they took her hand and that
was the last time i saw him until i
testified in court which was the next
year
and uh it was kind of interesting but uh
you know one thing i'd like to
that i always keep thinking about in
this situation is that
you know you talk about
that one bullet that one bullet i saw
that one bullet and i said well if he
was going to shoot him
more people or if he was going to shoot
it out with the police or anything he
would have more bullets
you know he would have a pocket full of
bullets you know to unload and put more
bullets in there and start shooting and
try to get away but he had one bullet
so to me my personal opinion is that one
bullet was for him
so you know i kind of call him the first
terrorist you know because he was going
to do what he had to do and he had that
one bullet there to you know take care
of his business and then in his life but
uh
but
that that's that's what happened i mean
it's
you know there's a
lot more you know you know i was able to
get the transcripts and
you know there's things that i forgot
that happened
but
this one thing that sticks in my mind is
that you know when he said i'll remember
3909 and to me
it's like thank god he's still in jail
you know
he'd come after me but uh
you know but
it was it was just uh
you know it was
a point where you never know law
enforcement
you know law enforcement is is a
location where you can be
where something might happen i mean
everybody else you go to your job and
stuff like that but law enforcement
you're out there when you get called
on a call it might be something like
this i mean some of them i mean i had 39
years and four months
but nothing was ever greater than this
you know and here i am 44 years later
talking about this
so you never know you you you never know
what might happen and you never know
when you'll be a witness to history
absolutely that's what we're all about
thank you art appreciate your sharing
that yes
now steve hughes 23 years i believe you
told me with the united states secret
service so you weren't on duty yet 44
years ago
so you weren't obviously
hands-on in terms of the policies in
place for the secret service back in
those days but
you know the history and i think you
certainly have a good understanding of
the differences between the secret
service protection back in 1968 for
presidential candidates and the level of
protection that presidential candidates
have today it's a stark contrast
certainly tell us about why
there was rayford johnson rosie greer
and
and bill berry
former fbi agent who were in charge of
the security for
a sitting united states senator whose
brother formerly the president of the
united states who had been assassinated
himself there must have been security
concerns for robert kennedy when he
decided to run for president and yet the
secret service wasn't providing security
why is that
well basically the reason we weren't
protecting was no law there's no
statutory authority for the secret
service to protect robert f kennedy and
i i do love the history and i love
listening to art and his recollections
of that day
a tragic day 44 years ago and it's
really
for us at the secret service and
specifically the division where we work
for campaign activities it's 44 years of
protection
anniversary today because on this date
we started candidate protection because
of this incident
so there was no law much like
it's going back historically many
presidents were assassinated and it
wasn't until 1901 when president
mckinley was assassinated that they
realized okay we better now act
despite the other assassinations of
presidents from lincoln on through
so that that caused congress to act and
create a law where we protected the
president after mckinley
and the same here they
only difference is
in 1968
congress acted the next day and they
they had public law in 93 31 where
authorized us to protect presidential
candidates and for president johnson to
get congress to act the next day has got
to be some type of record not since
matched on how quickly they're able to
get protection and the authority for the
secret service to protect presidential
candidates
and there were five presidential
candidates at the time as i understand
it on that day
within 24 hours the secret service
picked up protection on richard nixon
on eugene mccarthy who you mentioned
earlier also a nelson rockefeller
george wallace and harold stassen within
24 hours and then you know we grew the
rest of the campaign uh that year
because anyone who ran for president we
picked up uh
candidate protection on that year and
since then the criteria has been more
refined to who gets protection when get
they get protection and things like that
but at that time we acted immediately
and picked up
any count i think we had 12 candidates
in total that uh election year 1968. did
you get any additional resources i mean
it's wonderful for them to act and say
okay now we're going to give secret
service protection but it's another
thing to give you the manpower and the
other resources you need to make that
happen it was no notice we had no
manpower to to increase to we did get
some funding from congress
but the from what i've read the agents
that worked in a tremendous amount of
overtime in 1968 to accommodate this our
field offices rallied the agents and
they provided protection for these
candidates throughout the 1968 till the
election was over
so
taking off on that thought a bit about
who gets presidential or excuse me
secret service protection today
um i assume just announcing that you're
running for president of the united
states does not necessarily entitle you
to secret service protection what what
else do they have to do to qualify
well there's several criteria that needs
to be met to be
received secret service protection um
the first is that they have to request
the secret service protection so
that's the first criteria now our
secretary of the department of homeland
security ultimately will decide whether
the candidate receives protection there
are some guidelines that the secretary
can look into to see whether this person
is viable ultimately it's her decision
to make
but she does have an advisory panel made
up of the leadership of the house and
senate as well as a fifth member at
large i believe it's the senate
sergeant-at-arms this cycle who's an
advisor on that um
but certain certainly they have to be
from a uh
a party you know a recognized party as
part of it they have to have polling
data that we look at to see if they're
viable
matching funds
they have to enter in a certain number
of primaries and these are all
criteria for the candidate to meet now
uh
last cycle senator obama then senator
obama uh received the earliest secret
service protection in may of 2007. he
requested it and was granted by the
secretary back then so um
yeah it all depends on when the
candidate requests senator mccain
requested much later into 2008 so um
that's the most important thing is they
have to request the protection and then
meet the criteria and if they don't meet
all the criteria the secretary has to
deem them as a viable candidate after
checking with the advisory committee
from uh up on the hill and if the
candidate requests protection does that
include the family as well
uh statutorily it's really 120 days
prior to the election where the spouse
can receive protection
they can request to the secretary
for protection for a spouse or children
earlier but that would have to be via
executive order from the president for
us to then start protection which did
happen last cycle for mrs mccain and mrs
obama
okay there are
there is a candidate for president's
election
bobby kennedy who likes to press the
flesh
evan described the scenes the mob scenes
where people would try to pull him out
of the car and so forth
try to put yourself in in that situation
44 years ago how would the secret
service if they were protecting bobby
kennedy at that time how would you
handle it differently and what do you do
today that might make it a little safer
for people like bobby kennedy
well
the protection that we have we evolve
every year every incident we study and
we learn from
certainly
nothing's perfect in an open society
it's it's very tough for us to
accommodate the candidate and their
needs to go out and meet the
voters as well as do our job
successfully so there's a compromise
every day and every event
for all protection that we do
1968 looking at the photos and looking
at the diagrams from the ambassador
hotel i mean certainly we would have
learned to have a buffer zone for the
the crowd there we'd have an entry and
exit way for the candidate to get out
that would be clear
certainly the kitchen that he went
through was was very cluttered um and
and no one knew who was who back there
so things like that obviously we would
have been much more personnel involved
than um a couple of athletes
big as they were and uh the one private
security former fbi agent so we had more
personnel that we would have worked to
advance that site with the staff
that week prior so that we know where to
go have contingencies and that's what
we're all about is making contingencies
and planning our security efforts well
in advance so that there are no
surprises and we have a controlled
environment for our candidates again the
candidates want to get out there and
shake hands
and we try to work with them so they can
accomplish that
but we want to have a secure environment
for them to do it
when there's a campaign event these days
would the crowd that we see
shaking hands with the candidate would
they have been
walked through a magnetometer prior to
entering
that situation
well at certain points during each
campaign
we do
use different assets we increase it as
we get closer and closer as we move
along so certainly magnetometers is one
of the the tools that we use to screen
crowds at large events and and i'm
certain something like that in june of
the election year a crowd that size
would we would use magnetometers for so
that would have assisted us and again it
would our exit and entry route would
have been much cleaner than what what he
had available
yeah good point evan let me come back to
you
as with seemingly all of these types of
assassinations
shootings of
dignitaries and celebrities there's
always conspiracy theories
and obviously there were many that we
heard about with jfk's assassination
and maybe lesser known but certainly
almost as frequent we heard about
conspiracy theories related to bobby
kennedy's assassination
help us understand that and is there any
validity to the idea that there might
have been more than one gunman or other
people involved with sirhan sirhan
when something goes wrong people have to
explain it
uh and so that's how conspiracy theories
get going people just they can't cope
with it so there must be an explanation
there must be a conspiracy
most
my general belief as a journalist is
that we don't have any conspiracies
there are a lot of mistakes but there
aren't too many conspiracies not
impossible but they're much rarer than
people think in this particular case
when i was writing my bobby kennedy book
i wasn't quite sure how to deal with
this but at the time there was an
investigative reporter named dane
moldaya
who was well known done a lot of stuff
a hard driving guy and he set out
to prove that there had been a
conspiracy
by the time he done the research reached
the opposite conclusion
and that was pretty convincing to me an
investigative reporter who goes looking
for a conspiracy and comes out the other
end with no conspiracy
pretty convincing to me so i think the
evidence from everything i've read
is that sir on saran was just a loner
a mentally unbalanced guy
with a
political argument
and a cheap gun and that was it
and it wasn't there wasn't anything more
to that uh
i think the debate still goes on but i
think the evidence is
is
is more it's less complicated than the
jfk assassination where that debate will
go on forever
actually i think oswald was a lone
gunman in that case too but that's a
tougher call
well obviously you've looked at this
very closely i i read a few things
recently though that you know certainly
caught my attention preparing for
tonight's event
one is the fact that there was a woman
named nina rhodes hughes
apparently a television star of some
note back in those days a fervent bobby
kennedy supporter she was apparently
there that night and earlier this year
she apparently uh claimed as she had
apparently right after the shooting that
she felt there was a second gunman
involved and that they had never called
her as a witness in the trial of sirhan
sirhan and that they basically gave her
very short shrift in terms of her
testimony
during the investigation
now i understand the attorneys for
sirhan surhan earlier this year in
february actually filed a brief
with the courts that basically said with
this new evidence this woman that's come
forward uh that he should be given a
second look and maybe even paroled as a
result of this second gunman theory but
are you familiar with that and is there
any credence as far as you're concerned
i i i'm not but i have no doubt that
it's fake
okay very good
you may have heard the same then and i
just share this because it was it's
fascinating reading but perhaps that's
all it is as any good work of fiction is
but there was a girl in the polka dot
address that uh seemingly got a lot of
attention even to the point where
a member of the campaign staff for bobby
kennedy
said that he saw a woman in a polka dot
address along with a male companion
running out of the pantry area that
evening saying we shot him we shot him
and that apparently was corroborated by
a
la police officer who talked to an
elderly couple in the parking lot
seemingly giving the same type of
testimony to that officer again any
familiarity with the woman in the polka
dot address theory
i've written a lot about war
battle and when people are in traumatic
situations they see things it's very
hard to reconstruct what actually
happens in a battle because when people
are traumatized
they have very different memories of
what happened uh and if you read a clean
battle narrative i can pretty well
guarantee you that that's a contrivance
uh that that people don't really know
and the same thing happens in a scene
like this people will hear all sorts of
things we'll imagine all sorts of things
who knows what the woman in the polka
dot dress actually said
uh trauma and
and and and and and
drama
uh create work on your brain work on
your imagination and they produce
uh
impossible
results
again in this case
i think the conspiracy theories are
unproven a lot of people have looked at
it and and uh
you know sometimes it's hard to finally
resolve things this is particularly true
of the jfk assassination it's hard to
know for absolute certain because there
are too many
loose threads but uh i think in this
particular case the loose threads have
been pretty well tied up okay
all right um i'm curious you take sirhan
sirhan to the police station you've made
the arrest you filed the appropriate
paperwork
help us understand what happens then in
a case like this what agency for example
is it the fbi is it the los angeles
police department now that the secret
service is involved with protection do
they get involved with the actual
investigation
and
assist with the prosecution of sir han
surhan who was tried as you said about a
year later for this crime who had
jurisdiction at that point and what
happened to sirhan surhan after the
arrest
just just to get everything straight
here
i know there was trauma and drama but i
remember everything that happened there
but uh
you know i like i said this this was
back in 1968 i was 21 years old i was a
rookie cop so
i really didn't know much about what was
going down then but i know that uh he
was prosecuted in in the superior court
at the county los angeles so i'm
assuming that it was a uh he was tried
by uh
by superior court so he was tried by you
know the regular california supreme
court i know he's in
california state prison
and i know the investigation was
conducted by the los angeles police
department with help from other various
agencies i know that because uh
i remember when uh
they had a kennedy task force they call
it the kennedys that robert kennedy
little task force they had and even had
a mock-up they had mock-ups of the
pantry and how we walked because i had
to go over there they asked us how did
you go in we so we actually pointed we
came in through here and we went here he
was here we went out here so
i know that that investigation was
handled by the los angeles police
department
who who else was there i know i was
interviewed by quite a few people i was
depositioned by uh by sir hans uh
defense attorneys i was depositioned by
them
and uh so you know like i said a lot of
a lot of things were going on i was
being deposed here i was being
interviewed here by you know department
of brass and everybody wanted to know
what happened at that time
but
you know who was handling i know we were
handling it i know he got tried in
superior court so
i know he didn't get charged federally
so no i would think it'd have to be lapd
since there was no uh statute for
candidate protection at that time so
yeah that'd be a homicide lapd
different today though steve yeah the
fbi would
would run with this investigation
working with the local partners lapd if
it was to happen today okay
evan um perhaps you know the answer to
this question uh sirhan sirhan has now
been imprisoned for 44 years since the
shooting
never seen the light of day since then
he's been up for parole 14 times as i
understand it
fairly recently in fact he was denied
parole
do you believe sirhan sirhan will ever
be released from prison no
i think he's 68 years old now if i'm not
mistaken if it's parole's been denied
that many times i don't see what's going
to change it yeah yeah
point
um i'm going to do something now
letting our audience have a chance to
ask some questions
we have some microphones some staff with
microphones that can come to you
like you to feel free to ask any
question of our panelists that you think
you'd like to have them answer
if you just raise your hand and they'll
come greet you
that one over here
there you go
mr placencia i know it was such a
turbulent time
around the nation
um i was wondering what you saw as a law
enforcement officer
following
the assassination how was your daily
routine what was life like in los
angeles
after bobby kennedy was killed
well you know after
bobby kennedy was killed
you know my career basically went on
because i was still on a probationary
officer but there was a lot of things
going on there was a lot of marches
you know i grew up in the east l.a area
of los angeles and i know that
there was a lot of brown beret activity
over there
uh
in fact i think we even had a small mini
ride it was three years after the 1965
riot
and
i remember that
we were sent down to the watts area to
for that small riot
and
but there was a lot of things going on
you know there i i remember we were also
at the century city plaza they had a
large demonstration there i was sent
there for crowd control
and uh
so there was a lot of activity i mean it
was a you know they had a lot of
protesting the vietnam war
and uh
so it was busy but you know i was young
i saw this as all
you know new to me
let me give you a little short story i
grew up in the
east l.a area of los angeles
and when i
got on the job acts
i actually thought the west side was the
city of los angeles and when i got on
the job i found out the west side was
you know where ucla was and
i didn't realize where i i didn't
realize i was a minority until i got
into the police department because where
i grew up we were a majority you know
and also when i get into police
department i turn out to be a minority
officer so a lot of things were were
going down there you know it's basically
uh the los angeles police department was
everybody that
was teaching me or everybody that was in
the police department
a lot of them were from uh had been on
since 1946 45 you know a lot of them
were old-time
what i would say the old time there was
a lot of white male whites it was male
white dominated police department and uh
even for me to get in you know as a
latino that was a you know that was
something but you know and
but you know there was a lot of changes
going on a lot of things happening the
police department was changing
uh
the police department was being accused
of a lot of things and you know i mean
it was just a turbulent time for the
police department public and everything
so
evan maybe you could elaborate a little
i mean here you had a situation where
1963 president kennedy is assassinated
april of 1968 martin luther king
our great civil rights leader is
assassinated and then just uh three
months later bobby kennedy is
assassinated uh talk about the impact of
especially the culmination maybe with
the ken the robert kennedy assassination
how did it affect this nation and and
the future of our nation
uh i think a lot of people were really
seared by 1968 it was it had a kind of a
this is maybe too strong but a
pre-revolutionary feel there had been
when king was killed there were riots in
68 american cities that night this is
april 1968. uh there were riots at the
democratic convention in 1968 uh some of
which it was a police riot actually it
was the allegation that the mayor
daley's cops were a little too tough on
the demonstrators but it was a chaotic
scene
and it was frightening
there was a lot of student unrest
campuses were really in revolt the
vietnam war the civil rights movement
had stirred up the country and uh
president nixon
uh actually benefited from this that his
so-called silent majority these were
americans who wanted law and order you
know they wanted they wanted uh an end
to riots and crazy students and hippies
and all that they wanted they wanted law
and order and
nixon ran on that and won i'm not sure
bobby kennedy had survived that he would
have won i mean it's easy to say now the
great murder hero
first of all i'm not sure he would have
gotten the nomination because in those
days the democratic party was still run
by the bosses uh
and the bosses favored euward humphrey
johnson's vice president
he had many more delegates going into
chicago
so i you know maybe bobby could have by
the sheer passion and energy of his
campaign and his popularity could have
turned it around and convinced the
bosses that he was the guy but it was
not a sure thing
fred dutton bobby's body guy told me
that
and even if he had won the nomination
nixon was a formidable candidate running
on this law and order ticket because
people bobby kennedy was a hot guy
not that great on tv you know he sort of
there was steam coming off of him and he
was a little scary uh and people thought
you know is he gonna stir things up
he might have stirred things up in a
good way but he was an agitator he was a
radical in his own way and so i'm not
convinced
that he would have that he would have
won in 1968 but certainly that night he
had a lot of momentum
he did and you could argue these things
endlessly and there's a lot of mythology
about it uh
he was a he was a great i mean he was a
i was saying in my book that he was a he
was in the process of becoming great
uh he had been a good attorney general
he had taken on organized crime nobody
else had done that he had taken on the
civil rights movement i mean he he
persuaded his brother in 1963
to introduce the silver what became the
civil rights act of 1964. johnson gets
the credit for it because he passed it
but the person who introduced that bill
was john f kennedy 1963. now think about
this for a second
the base of the democratic party
the base of the democratic party was the
solid south
by introducing that civil rights bill
kennedy is basically kissing off the
base of his party
how many politicians today would do that
i mean just if you if you think about
the electoral math on this and he wasn't
all that happy about it but bobby goaded
and prodded his brother that this is the
right thing to do
and in june of 1968
excuse me june of 1963
president kennedy went on national
television to call for a civil rights
act we forget 1963 black people could
not go to you know the bathroom to
restaurants to hotels the south was
completely segregated not so long ago
and we needed federal legislation to
change that
we got it but but jack kennedy was the
guy who introduced it and he said you
know we have a moral obligation he said
as old as the scriptures and as clear as
the constitution
uh to do something about this and it was
a politically very brave thing to do
uh and uh the kennedys if that was all
they did
deserve credit for that kind of
political courage again i'm not seeing a
whole lot of that in our current uh
political environment and the candidates
were very political i don't mean to say
that they were they they were very
political but um
they did a brave thing on this and they
did a lot of brave things bobby kennedy
was a brave person there's no question
about that precisely because he was
frightened
he overcame his own fear
his own fear of death he was very
fatalistic about getting shot
he had many conversations in the spring
of 1968 where people warned him that he
was going to be killed one time there
was a supposedly a rifleman scene on the
roof
his advisor said you got to go out the
back he said no no i'm going out the
front door
i'm going at the front door i got to
show that i'm not afraid
and uh that's the way he was
uh he was he was a he was a brave guy as
i say
uh and i think in the process of
becoming a great man but we'll never
know
i think you write in your book by the
way uh i was reading an excerpt that
talked about he did a lot of that he was
the gritty
courageous guy in part because his
father thought he was weak yeah and he
grew up with that kind of uh
on a show
if you will yes they call him the runt
of the family he was he described
himself as a little kid he's actually a
great i talk about him to school
students because
his brother jack was glamorous and his
sister kik and joe jr they were known as
the golden trio and they were
good-looking and popular and athletic
and bobby was this little guy by his own
description fell down a lot dropped
things was depressed his brother jack
called him black robert he got kicked
out of high school for cheating
he was not a good athlete he was a
fierce athlete he was not very he was a
cd student he had everything going
against him but he found in his own
weakness
strength
he was unlike more than other members of
his family he was able to reach out to
poor people to the dispossessed to
people who have left behind he
understood juvenile delinquents as they
were called in those days kids like him
who had been forgotten in some way or or
had a lot of strikes against them now
it's hard to bobby kennedy was a very
rich privileged kid but he had a way of
reaching across class and money
reaching out to people who had
nothing and who voted for him i mean
they're photographs of him he when he
drove through a black area town he was
mobbed by these black kids running along
they loved him because they sensed in
him his empathy he was able to convey
that through his speeches his body
language his manner and it came from
being
what they called the runt of the family
he had an empathy that the other
kennedys
you know lacked and it made him it was
the key to i think the beginning of his
greatness
other questions
jerry
wait for our microphone if you will
thank you and thank you very much to the
panel i haven't had to disagree with you
from uh those of us from massachusetts
would say that uh bobby kennedy probably
would have been a great candidate for
president but thank you
this i guess goes to badge number three
909 as someone who's entering his uh
final year in 32 years of service i want
to thank you for your service after and
quite a quite a stellar career and uh
thank you for being here this evening
at the risk of sounding like a
a person who's a
fair uh what do you call the people
conspiracy theorists
you mentioned a great point which was
there was an eight shot 22
and during that time
there was a security officer who
was
working that evening who has also had a
gun in that in the
in the ambassador hotel a gun that's
never allegedly never been recovered
there was also uh allegedly 13 shots
in the ambassador hotel and i think the
irony of this whole story is that the
ambassador hotel is not what dealey
plaza is or what the um jfk uh
assassination is where you have a museum
that's made it was torn down to be a
school i believe it is today by one of
the victims who
i think is a doctor today i think that
that's probably something that bobby
kennedy would have probably wanted but
yet
it takes away i think from what we're
here today to talk about which is
history and i think if you could expound
upon a
um was that
security guard armed and were there more
than eight shots fired within the
building
again you know
i was a probationary officer and
basically i didn't have anything to do
with that investigation other than my
part
and i know it i know what you're talking
about because they said there was
more shots but
you know this has been gone
there's books been written on this right
there's books been written on this
about how many shots and about that
security guard and
you know i
i don't know i don't know i didn't even
you know about the gun i mean i can't
see a a security guard carrying a 22
you know i would expect them to carry 38
because that's what we used to carry
back then
um
i don't i have to tell you i don't know
all i know is
what i saw
and i saw this
22 long bullet in his pocket one
and i know that the gun that was used
was an ivor johnson 22
8 shot revolver
and i know that's in custody
and
that
yet that is now a school and at the time
they wanted to make it some type of a
memorial
that pantry area
and uh but
the school board they decided to just
knock it down and it's now school i
think it's he may call the robert f
kennedy school and uh and it's still
there i mean it's right there at 3 400
wilshire
but you know i wish i could say hey
you know you think about it and i'm
thinking god why couldn't i had two or
three years on the job
i mean it would have been completely
different what i've asked them what i've
talked to and what i've done
but you know i just happen to only have
three weeks
so i basically you know i was just being
though
i was doing what i was told
you know and uh
you know hindsight
maybe i should have done a lot of other
things but
you know they they talk about that
sirhan was you know maybe crazy or maybe
whatever but i don't know you know you
think about with everything going on
this guy was able to take a look at my
badge and say 3909
i mean he must have had something going
with him i mean you know so
uh you know it's uh
now when i think about it i
i can you know i think about it all the
time when i'm asked you know and usually
this happens about this time every year
but uh all i know is what i did
you know and
it happened when i was three weeks on a
job and like you know you know it could
anything can happen at any time
you just at the right place at the right
time and you're a part of history
or you know
nothing really happens and i keep saying
you know and i know my wife's going to
get on me about that
all right one thing that i don't think
we covered here but you've certainly
told me in earlier conversation is that
and this is striking to me
that uh you mentioned the timeline by
the time you got there got sir han out
of there it might have been as long as a
half hour or more perhaps from the time
you got the call from the time of the
shooting at 12 15 a.m on pacific time
june 5th uh 1968. you said when you took
sir and surhan out of there bobby
kennedy was still lying in the pool of
blood there on the floor is that correct
yes you know
actually the first person taken out of
there was uh sirhan
and he was the first because we were in
there we walked right in
we got him we arrested him we took him
out
bobby kennedy and the other victims were
farther down into the pantry area but
like i said we didn't know that there
because there were so many people there
and it should be noted as you alluded to
there that five other people were
actually shot and injured uh in that
shooting incident uh bobby kennedy was
the only one who died
and i was also
interested to read that rosemary clooney
apparently was there a furman bobby
kennedy supporter and she was taken away
to the hospital because of a nervous
breakdown
after the event she was not shot but a
lot of celebrities there george plimpton
was there for example
among many others so
the kennedy aura
certainly affected a lot of people and a
lot of people were very hurt by what
happened that night
other questions from the audience
uh this is for mr thomas and it has a
an indirect relationship especially to
our museum what did you uh what did your
research show when uh bobby kennedy was
attorney general about his relationship
with j edgar hufu
it was pretty bad
uh
hoover was a you know force unto himself
he had lived through a lot of presidents
and he kept his
power through a number of means but one
of
one of those means was having a file on
whoever was in office
and uh
this is a problem for bobby kennedy
because bobby wanted the fbi to get in
the
into the organized crime game which it
had not done and they they did they they
did get him
and he wanted the fbi to get involved in
civil rights and they did but he had
trouble controlling hoover whoever had
some pushback and this gets a little
complicated but hoover had a way of
sending memos over to the attorney
general just to let him know what he
knew
one thing that he knew
was that the president united states had
shared a girlfriend with the head of the
mob in chicago momo giancana
judith exner was her name
jack kennedy had a lot of girlfriends
and one of them was
a mafia mall and the head of the fbi
knew that
and that was a pretty embarrassing fact
and that was good job security
for j edgar hoover when that memo went
across
he also
pushed
kennedy for authority to wiretap martin
luther king
and this is gets very complicated but he
was he had some
ability to force kennedy to do it
because
there's another woman named ellen romesh
who was alleged to have had sex with
president kennedy who was uh
also alleged to be an east german spy
and rfk and his buddies got her out of
the country
uh but uh
during a the bobby baker scandal her
name came up
and
bobby kennedy needed hoover to go to the
hill and say stop this investigation
the price for that
was permission
to wiretap king
uh and uh you can't really make the
stuff up i mean it is it's just you know
if you're doing a hollywood movie you
can't make it up
uh so uh the
hoover was able to essentially blackmail
uh the president and his brother uh
kennedy bobby kennedy hated this of
course
uh didn't like uh would demand that
hoover come see him usually the
procedure was the attorney general went
to see the director
bobby would insist that the director
come see
him they're in the same building in
those days
hoover didn't like that so it was a test
of wills i would have said if bobby
kennedy was elected president the first
person he'd fire would be hoover but i'm
not sure that because that file was
still in hoover's drawer
you know if i may
i another you had asked the question
about the uh the ambulance and when
bobby kennedy was taken
and i was just thinking that the uh at
the time
central receiving hospital was the main
hospital in that area where they used to
dispatch the ambulances from and that
central receiving hospital was about two
miles from
the ambassador hotel
so when that call came out ambulance
shooting that ambulance would have been
dispatched to the ambassador hotel
because we usually get the calls about
the same time and then since there was a
shooting involved there we had victims
so
i'm thinking that what happened was that
probably right after we had left the
ambulances
got there for ambulance got there and
that's when they probably took kennedy
right outside he probably was out of
there maybe 20
20 minutes after we left
because when we left they had not got
there yet
i think we need to wrap up and let me
just offer a few closing comments uh
again fascinating discussion uh so many
facts and and uh the stories associated
with this assassination
um i you mention art the uh
the role that fate plays in a law
enforcement's career and i think we
could argue the same here in the
assassination of robert kennedy
not only did it have an amazing effect
on your career as a law enforcement
professional but it certainly had a
major impact on our nation at the time
and certainly moving forward into the
future years as evan and others have
alluded to
the fact of the matter is bobby kennedy
after he gave his uh speech his victory
speech
was intending to go meet with some
supporters in another part of the hotel
when the press clamored for him to come
speak to them at a press conference so
he was actually rerouted at the last
minute
through that kitchen area where he was
assassinated and we can only speculate
as to whether or not
sir hans surhan if he didn't get him
that night would he have tried again
we'll never know the answer to that
sirhan sirhan was tried a year later
his defense by his attorneys was
diminished responsibilities meaning he
was not clear-headed when he did it in
fact sir and sirhan to this day says he
does not recall the incident at all
and and that's his story and he's
sticking to it and and the bottom line
is
he never denied
shooting and killing robert kennedy and
he never indicated that there was a
conspiracy of any sort those are
attorneys that are now making that
argument on his behalf
let me say this
i was moved truly as all of us i think
were at the time ted kennedy's eulogy to
his brother and i'll just quote an
excerpt from it it says my brother need
not be idealized or enlarged in death
beyond what he was in life to be
remembered simply as a good and decent
man who saw wrong and tried to write it
saw suffering and tried to heal it
saw war and tried to stop it
as he said many times in many parts of
this nation to those he touched and who
sought to touch him
some men see things as they are and say
why
i dream things that never were and say
why not
tonight on the 44th anniversary of the
assassination of robert f kennedy
i want to thank
the panelists who joined us here tonight
evan thomas art placencia steve hughes
for sharing
their perspective of this historic event
and the impact it had on their lives and
on the nation
i certainly want to thank our sponsors
from target who
sponsor our series called witness to
history brad brecki is here with us
tonight representing target
i also want to recognize a couple of
dignitaries with us here tonight we have
todd jones director of atf is here as
well as teresa chambers the chief of the
u.s park police among many other
notables here in the audience so i thank
all of you for sharing in this very
special evening as i said earlier this
will be preserved on film for posterity
sake hundreds of years from now people
will be
listening to the recollections and and
the comments made here tonight about
this milestone in law enforcement and in
american history so i want to thank all
of you for joining us uh good night to
all